okay no one ever called me that before
okay ah I feel so happy right now and at
the same time I'm kind of sad because we
have had all this wonderful speeches
tonight and that answer right now I'm
going to keep this short for the sake of
everyone here I want to thank my family
and my friends you know who you are I
want to thank most importantly my sound
designer Carson French and my composure
Austin ray they made this film and it
wouldn't exist without you guys I also
want to thank my advisor bill who mentor
me throughout this entire project and
for all four years that I had at Chapman
University I also like to thank the
entire staff and faculty have dodged
they were really the ones who shaped me
into the RS I am today I was like
staying someone that doesn't get enough
recognition and it is them serious
admissions officer who about five years
ago saw my application so my grades and
still accept me to the program so
whoever you are Good Samaritan
admissions officer this is for you and
and of course I would like to thank the
academy I've always wanted to say that I
could be up here all night and I still
be able to convey how much this means to
me so I want to thank the governor's the
members the staff Mary brian james Sean
Hector Daniel if I forgot someone my
deepest apologies and i'll buy you in
and out thank you thank you all